cherry chaque soir asteur si je vais
vous raconter c'est baba raconter
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
l'histoire des télé crochets les télé
crochets ces concours musicaux ces
concours on peut chanter bas c'est en
voilà je vous le dis c'est elle est là
la toute première reine du télé crochet
155 son nom ne vous dit rien mais son
prénom peut-être elle s'appelle mireille
artus c'était elle qui a lancé le télé
crochet à la craie le petit
conservatoire de la chanson
le conservatoire pour appeler
conservatoire de mireille c'était un peu
une nounou de chanteurs et vous allez
voir dans cet extrait une des toutes
premières télés de françoise hardy
françoise hardy mais françoise hardy et
bien regarder en live dans le petit
conservatoire de mireille c'était ça le
premier télé crochet jusqu'à se voir on
va faire l'histoire et vous allez voir
des images de me regarder ces parties
très souvent je pense à vous comme je
pense aux autres élèves mais j'étais un
petit peu agacé parce que je trouvais
que vous traitiez avec votre métier vous
ne le faites pas comme il fallait
vous voulez pas apprendre à gagner votre
vie je vous ai suppliés d'aller
auditionné dans les cabarets non le pad
il faut c'est maintenant le contact avec
le public qui vous est nécessaire si
vous arrivez à en placer une vous aurez
de la chance tu sais pas si tu es 10
passes
il se passe rien et moi je suis là
plantée comme à shanghai
quant à l'anti santé qu'on veut pas
qu'ils chantent et les dieux
et la main
dans la main
ils s'en vont amoureuse sans faire du
mal de mer
oui mais moi je vais seul par les rues
la main pleine
oui mon
veste car personne
et oui vous nous rejoignez vous êtes
dans baba raconte et chaque soir je vous
raconter une histoire d'un grand truc de
télé ce soir j'ai décidé de vous
raconter l'histoire des télé crochets
ben ça c'était le premier télé crochet
pour les jeunes qui nous regarde moi moi
je connaissais pas ça du tout un joli
c'était l'ancêtre de the voice un joli
et c'était mireille du petit
conservatoire vous allez voir ensuite
que johnny hallyday même johnny hallyday
il a fait un télé crochet c'est
incroyable je vous montrais cerdan
l'instant oui valérie bénaïm oui oui
vous savez mireille convient de voir
vous connaissez la chanteuse sabine
paturel
les belges ont changé et chocolat non
non non non
bouteflika ça n'a rien à voir ces corps
et charli encor une famille sabine
paturel c'est des bêtises
merci de lait chocolat voilà l'éviter
donc et ben et et paracels sabine
paturel a balancé son bilan dix ans que
chaque fois qu'elle allait cependant
abattoirs elle était méchante elle seule
elle faisait pleurer les élèves et que
sabine paturel pleurais tous les jours
dans tous les jeux c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça qu'après le faisais rien que des
bêtises je vous le dis même line renaud
qui mise aux voix la haute et décrocher
donc le 18 avril 1960 elle recevait deux
jeunes chanteuses de jeunes chanteurs
line renaud en direct à la télévision
c'était un des premiers concours de télé
crochet ce qui donne cette archive
incroyable puisque c'est la toute
première télé de johnny hallyday et oued
jonas et sa télé crochet et céline
renaud qu'il avait organisée regardez ça
il faut maintenant présenter aux
téléspectateurs
le jeune johnny hallyday qui est votre
filleul qui vient de chanter et bien
johnny hallyday venait il a 16 ans je
crois du soc 17 voyez ça change tout je
voudrais bien poser des questions à mon
filleul mais je vous préviens tout de
suite mais il répond par oui ou par non
un century non c'est monsieur oui non et
je crois qu'on doit sa la timidité de
ses 17 ans est ce que c'est votre
premier choix sont souvent sans faire
d'autres bien sûr bien sûr val
non et bien c'est bien sûr maintenant et
bien je crois que pour ça il faut le
demander aux téléspectateurs parce que à
la fin de tout c'est le public qui est
seul juge
moi je vous ai présenté mon filleul à
bien savoir s'il a une carrière devant
lui ou s'il n'atteint fort ou pas elle
johnny hallyday est franchement c'est
pas énorme ces croyances johnny hallyday
s'était il a fait un télé crochet donc
jeunes aidés tout comme mon frérot kenji
alors on continue dans les télé crochets
et ans après on en 1965 elle télé
crochet s'installe vraiment et remplace
le radio crochet le jeu de la chance
était présenté par amex appelé raymond
marcillac c'était le nikos de l'époque
raymond marcillac salut nous serons en
eaux commencent à bâle où tout va bien
seul tous les sermons marcillac et on ya
découvert une chanteuse que j'aime et
que j'adore elle aussi elle a été
découvert dans un télé crochet c'est
mireille mathieu elle avait 19 ans
regardez montmirail survolé nous je sais
pas où je cours après la radicale c'est
non
ce qu'on dit
ce nom a
ce nageur
n'oublions pas que c'était les dimanches
qui a découvert mireille mathieu c'est
le jeu de la chance et le plus beau
cadeau de noël que nous pouvons lui
souhaiter pour elle c'est de devenir une
grande vedette une grande dame de la
chanson je crois qu'elle le mérite
elle a vraiment ce qu'il faut pour ça
bravo mille rêves
mais si l'espagne caire alors voilà donc
raymond marcillac lui c'était une mycose
de l'époque et à côté mme à mireille
mathieu ben voilà c'est là qu'a démarré
puis est immense carrière carrière
internationale pour mireille qui nous
regardent tous les soirs et donc elle
avait fait donc ça l'avait fait donc ce
qu'on appelle le jeu de la chance
puis après il ya eu 10 luxe guy lux donc
là lui et guy lux et c'est le taulier
aussi guy lux étaient un petit peu voilà
lui il faisait tout et n'importe quoi
qui luxe tu pouvais le voir avec des
vachettes
le lendemain il vient tiercé guy lux
hills et où guy lux le lendemain il
faisait une émission de cuisine
guy lux il s'en foutait il était partout
c'était lui le xterra mans le patron et
il n'y a pas eu grand chose en fait
après en télé crochet jusqu'aux années
2000 parce qu'il a été complètement
laissé tomber le télé crochet les
concours de chant jusque dans les années
2000 et en 2001 il ya eu le lancement de
pop star pop star avec cartonné en 2001
lors de son lancement
4,7 millions de téléspectateurs et il ya
eu le couronnement des l5 on s'en
rappelle souvenez-vous costard c'était
donc il essayait de trouver un groupe de
bâtir un groupe
voilà et de le lancer à fond et il ya eu
les l5 regarder ça c'était en 2001
[Musique]
à toi tu ouvres
les yeux
est ce que tu as
[Musique]
attendu chez lui
ben oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était temps
c'est tout
je dois tout
et oui alors donc à une pop star où il
était chargé de découvrir un groupe pop
star alors vraiment eu ma nièce qui a vu
la star ac avant non pop star est
arrivée avant la star ac et justement en
2001 sur tf1 il décide de mixer télé
réalité d'enfermement ce qui est des
lofts avant sur m6 et musique et ils ans
la star academy et vous rappelez du
titre de la chanson officielle de la
première star ac ou pas c'était quoi la
musique directement voulait tamuz inique
reprise de nicoletta là là là c'est
l'amnésique c'est parti regarde
[Musique]
je ne
il est
non
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là les ics votes par appel
j'avais un poids qu'il oubliait toujours
ses volets fabrique c'est là alors il y
avait jean pascal d'ailleurs qui avait
tant finale ce qui était très populaire
jean pascal qui avait tant finale et
contre qui il avait été en finale note
jean pascal que j'embrasse disait alors
quand on utilise rtl fr et je crois
qu'il y avait eu un petit truc contre de
jean pascal et jennifer n'y a pas à
beinheim et un petit oui bien sûr
d'ailleurs un peu étonné sur cette
histoire d'amour entre eux entre les
deux qui étaient dans leur descente les
sentes ac milan d'ailleurs la cl et
j'adore moi je les adore les alors
regardé toute première saison remportée
évidemment par jennifer à cette époque
les victoires avait même leur place dans
le jt de 20h qui parlait du gagnant de
la star ac
or vous dire aujourd'hui le gagnant de
la star academy c'est ça qui fait de la
peine non mais ça fait de la peine
aujourd'hui une mère tu peux même pas
donnée gagnante the boss de l'année
dernière j'aime être acquises et je
crois que c'est maurice figues ou iris
uni ruf évolué bon ils se regardent et
jennifer quoi 2001 la star ac' rhône et
non metalcore non non t'inquiète pas ton
maire de pau avec ça nathan merde pas
exact
[Musique]
jennifer est l'heureux élu dé
téléspectateurs une tranchée en lui
accordant une majorité de leurs
suffrages
l'attaché de presse de nice l'emportent
sur mario un barman parisien d'origine
italienne
c'est la fin d'une épreuve par
élimination pour cette jeune femme de 19
ans qui s'est distingué deux cent mille
candidats au départ
avant d'affronter depuis octobre 16
finalistes trois mois de travail acharné
pour ces élèves d'une école de spectacle
télévisé qui ont suivi des cours de
chant danse et comédie dispensés par des
professionnels
semaine après semaine le public a écarté
les moins bons
[Musique]
victorieuse jennyfer n'est en fait qu'au
début de son aventure dans le monde de
la chanson avec un million d'euros en
poche à titre d' avance elle a gagné le
droit d'enregistrer un premier album
expérience très belle aventure
c'est le début d'une autre alors
maintenant il va falloir assurer il va
falloir j'ai travaillé très dur et je
suis prête à travailler je suis une
bosseuse
eh ouais et il ya jean alors c'était
contre mario la finale jean pascal il
est perdu en demi finale
jean pascal parce que moi j'étais à fond
pour jean pascal qui était dit que je
kiffais déjà à l'époque sans le
connaître et jean pascal may me voilà el
mami voilà et il m'a mis immanuel
m'appela qui le pauvre jean pascal
marchi ou lembras guibal le pauvre jean
pascal wilhem et chaud lapin on vous
racontait décoiffé crochet effectivement
les étés dans les gîtes et les gagnants
et moi le lendemain c'est un but que
jenifer c'est en tant qu'artiste ses
décors explosif que je présente avec
frédéric xavi elle vient était tout
petit mil et à l'époque c'est elle se
rendait pas compte à quel point l
influencer les jeunes filles parce
qu'elle était apte histoire brisée par
un coiffeur c'est prendre au mot l île
mais qu'à chaque fois des petites
barrettes et ses bars est là seulement
blais le le tour de force en acheter
plus 200 + 300 points de vente rappelle
face et dans la star academy
le lendemain j'osais je dirais whatfor
qui était déjà très très belle je la
trouve très mignon franchement j'aime
beaucoup
alors jennifer elle garde un très bon
souvenir de cette aventure elle en
parlait sur le plateau de c'est à vous à
l'époque
regardez elle disait à l'époque on était
les beatles regardez on a vécu trois
mois très intenses en fait plein de
rebondissements découvre et on n'avait
pas conscience de l'ampleur que ça avait
à l'extérieur et puis en même temps s'en
rendaient plus ou moins content quand
vous étiez descamps 700 kg on est encore
c'étaient les beatles quand on est sorti
sa première touche est née une tournée
mais c'était c'était l'euphorie la plus
totale donc en fait on était dans ce
dans ce tourbillon médiatique on se
rendait pas d'un compte on voit raconte
l'histoire des télé crochets c'est vrai
que jenifer c'est vrai que c'était un
allié on était les beatles étaient pure
il est mort oui gilles verdez mais cpl
elle exagère à peine parce que à
l'époque ça n'avait pas été banalisé
comme maintenant c'était les produits
chez tel événement c'étaient les stars
du psg
c'est comme s'ils s'étaient échappés à
l'époque salaire pour les moyens et on
les voyait partout c'était un vrai
événement populaire et tout le monde
regardait c'était génial calories
gilbert les beetle qui était il était
connu mondiale ama il est plus gras
jennifer
les pères l'humanisme regarder juste
rené cj là c'est pas gilbert ce qui
donne alors en 2004 le grand vainqueur
c'est grégory lemarchal grégory
lemarchal
pour les plus jeunes c'était ça et c'est
vrai que tout le monde dit que c'était
pour beaucoup le plus grand vainqueur de
la star ac
au niveau de la voix regarde en détresse
[Musique]
j'aime pour
sur elle
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grégory lemarchal une voix
exceptionnelle vous savez quel biopic de
grégory lemarchal qui va arriver sur tf1
plus il a déjà été tourné donc il va
arriver je pense à la rentrée et c'est
vrai que j'ai eu la chance de le
rencontrer mais grégory qui était un
garçon un amour de mecs voilà je l'avais
adorée
il était venu me voir un jour à la radio
et je l'aimé énormément et c'est vrai
que il est atteint de mucoviscidose et
décède le 30 avril 2007 grégory
lemarchal et la france bien entendu
toute la france est en émoi qu'on me
dise tu es une immense star grégory
regardons les obsèques de grégory
lemarchal à chambéry une cérémonie très
émouvante suivie par une foule imposante
la disparition du jeune chanteur atteint
de mucoviscidose a touché beaucoup de
monde sur place denis sébastien thiéry
simonet une avalanche de fleurs blanches
ils sont plus d'un millier de fans
restés à l'extérieur de l'église des
anonymes venus parfois de loin qui ont
tenu à assister aux obsèques de leur
idole
c'est important d'être là pour moi
aujourd'hui parce que tout ce qu'il le
méritait pas ce qui nous a donné tout ce
qu'il a pu à son public il avait
tellement de force tellement de courage
que va donc si maintenant il est là pour
lui ça fait une paye nombre de deux
de voir partir si vite on aurait espéré
qu'il ait quelques années de plus
travers plusieurs de ses représentants
comme marc lavoine ou patrick fiori le
monde de la chanson lui rend aussi
hommage
c'est ce que j'appelais quoi droit juste
nickel pas d' embrouille
rare de voir des jeunes amants comme lui
aussi haut
je me suis au top quoi grégory lemarchal
donc nous quitte en 2007 et 2008
c'est la dernière année de la star ac
sur tf1 ils arrêteront l'année suivante
et en 2012 le format est racheté par la
chaîne nrj12 et à la présentation on
retrouve matthieu delormeau et tonya
kinzinger vous savez très sympathique et
dans sous le soleil
rappelez vous de tout premier lancement
de matthieu delormeau dans la star
academy et regarder
d'aventura leurs feuilles tous les
bienvenus la star academy nouvelle
génération c'est parti
bonsoir
100 nature bonsoir à tous l'académie tu
fais plus grandes stars lacaune est des
plus grands talents très content et tous
les passionnés de celle de chants et de
danses rêve de l'intégrer et
soir 14 ans ce rêve de bien faire cela
dans mad sudinfos pourquoi il est bien
il est mort au pays des idées 10e
voilà donc à près égale une saison sur
nrj 12 et après ça coûtait trop cher sur
nrj 12
ils l'ont arrêtée savez très bien marché
un million sept cent mille personnes à
début je vous dis car academy sur des
rails youssef un énorme carton le retour
et moi en parallèle je présentais la
nouvelle star sur scène je me rappelle
très bien et en 2003 alors c'est pas ma
salle à ma nouvelle star en 2003 en 2003
c'est la toute première saison doit la
recherche de la nouvelle star qui avait
été aussi un énorme carton d'audience et
sur m6 c'était le premier titre avant de
s'appeler tout simplement nouvelle star
au départ c'était à la recherche de la
nouvelle star
particularité c'est le tout premier télé
crochet ou la chanson en français est
obligatoire ça j'avais oublié
regardez ce que ça donnait d'ailleurs
[Musique]
jo
vienne
[Musique]
dufort
son
[Musique]
ça
et oui laisser entrer le soleil s à ce
thème on a reconnu jonathan cerrada dans
nouvelle star
nouvelle star mais je kiffais moi je
voulais je vous dise où je kiffais plus
en fait la nouvelle star que la star ac
même si la star ac' balaji rentrer
dedans mais ce que j'aime bien jean
pascal à l'eau début mais c'est vrai que
la nouvelle star on aime bien l'idée de
jury c'était un truc de fou et en 2008
il ya une candidate de la nouvelle star
qu'on adore et juste pour ce moment j'ai
envie de lui dire merci
cette candidate qui à fait nouvelle star
et qu'on adore kinase a donné un moment
exceptionnel je vous donne un indice
dans un instant à qui vous pensez tout
de suite on peut dire moi je pense à un
papillon papillon de lumière cindy
sanders
j'ai beau dire que cindy sanders en fait
avait fait la nouvelle star et c'est
vrai que mine de rien ça ça c'est du
très très bon regarde jusque vous
arrêter de chanter je chantais comme en
les candidats venaient chez les
carpentier
[Musique]
lui même
et ça c'est hélas elle ça enlève ça on
l'écouté ça on l'écouté comme des
poussins papillon de lumière papillon de
race traçant des collections au bout
raconte l'histoire des télé crochets et
c'est vrai que la nouvelle star c'était
été du très très lourd un ouais ça oui
valérie bègue avec eux maintenant cindy
sanders a eu une carrière incroyable
ouais elle et elle a été prise en main
par un grand couturier qui l'a amené
dans un cabaret en allemagne c'est
maintenant c'est de supersport en
allemagne et lé voilà elle vit sa
meilleure mine
c'est en formation extraordinaire c'est
thierry imbert qui l'a prise en grande
anse où son nom est venu danser thierry
kiri strudel thierry strudel oui oui
la grosse différence je trouve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand on élimine des
candidats dans ce box
il s'entoure merveilleux vous ferez le
carrière formidable c est quoi qu'on en
pense dans la nouvelle star quoi qu'on
pense des jurys ça balançait sa balance
et les ont regardés autant pour les
candidats voir mais plus amène au jury
de jury daewoo est maintenant entre 2004
et 2007 il ya eu une autre à notre télé
crochet alors c'est un autre délire je
vous le dis tout de suite c'était
vraiment complètement autre chose c'est
jeudi un télé crochet au feu de bois à
l'ancienne
et quand je peux 2004 2007 c'est pascal
sevran qui lui aussi s'était essayé à
l'exercice avec entrée d'artistes
regardez ça le titre est magnifique et
là ça donne ça alors c'est du style
pascal sevran pascal sevran c'est comme
aujourd'hui
non y'a pas un gardien pas
[Musique]
aucun jour notre histoire
ce décret dans les changer
et alors c'était une barque à parce
qu'il était venu sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle
à l'époque avec thierry ardisson parce
qu'elles seront et il était venu
présenter le gagnant de la première
édition qui s'appelait alan alan vermeer
c'était en 2004
on va dire que les invités présents ce
soir-là dénigrer un peu son concept et
ses petits protégés et regarder pascal
sevran et cv l'air de ouf parce qu'il y
ait des monts télé crochet je le
défendrai jusqu'au bout regarder ça
quels conseils donneriez-vous à un jeune
chanteur qui débute d'abord une
détermination formidable c'est l'idée
qu'on ne peut faire ça et rien d'autre
deuxième chose ne surtout pas s'occuper
d'être à la mode parce que là c'est raté
comme un moment puis à peu près dans
toute l'histoire de la chanson française
mais ils sont à l'abri de ça suffit ces
joueurs mais je retiens ma phrase parce
que sans ça je finis ma phrase il s'agit
des jeunes gens moi j'en ai rien à faire
je deviens partir le bus ici je finis ma
phrase et je hais je vous dis que il n'y
a pas d'exemple quasiment de vedette de
music hall de la chanson française qui
ont qui sont arrivés en semoule en se
couchant dans la mode
quels conseils donneriez-vous un vieux
chanteur qui débute encore jeu d'être en
bonne santé chanter plus longtemps parce
que il fois il faut pas un poids y est
ça gèle ses adjectifs thierry vieux vous
allez être bientôt que je suis depuis
longtemps bien quels conseils
donneriez-vous à pascal sevran jeune je
donnerai un conseil à pascal sevran
queue à cette heure ci il va te coucher
bonsoir
[Musique]
dans la ville
[Applaudissements]
derrière le bon bilan à tallinn en garde
ou le pauvre ça va ça va ça ça m'a fendu
le coeur je voulais lui faire un fondu
le coeur les séries en 2009
il ya une autre image que voulez vous
montrer parce que c'est une grande image
des talents show ces images cultes
c'est la plus grande star vraiment de
tout les télé crochets de toutes les
personnes que 20 télé crochet c'est la
plus grande star à votre avis de qui
s'agit-il
la plus grande star de tous les terrains
c'est quand j'ai lu rang de star mais ce
n'est pas là c'est parce que moi je vous
demande est la plus grande star mondiale
elle avait 47 ans quand elle s'est
présentée à la suffit
oui ça exactement dit susan boyle
c'était la version anglaise d'incroyable
talent ça s'appelle britain's got talent
tu veux dire la grande bretagne a du
talent bas c'est normal in d'âge de 47
ans arrive sur scène tout le monde croit
au canular et elle chante
hélas si l'arrivée la maison des
jésuites arrogance jésus revient jésus
reviens parmi elles et à bien y regarder
susan boyle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais attendez attendez est les mecs si
elle a 47 ans déjà frères non si déjà
déjà ses sourcils sont plus jeunes c'est
sûr et certain que la somme de la
personne et sur ce qu'ils sont plus
jeunes c'est sûr et certain
mais je vous le dis 47 ans susan boyle à
la série de 47 ans il paraît alors
j'aimerais qu'on revoie parce que moi je
suis toujours impressionné vous aussi
vous dites on aimerait bien voir ça
parce que le moment quand elles arrivent
et quand elle commence à chanter sans
rigoler c'est un truc de ouf
rené scetbon street demain susan boyle
crackable traitons des liens non je me
rappelle de cette émission théorique
hommes avaient tous été copiés cette
hausse est en grande bretagne et étalon
de toi et québec est qu'ils avaient tous
été scotché risque de voir les mais le
jury ferrotypée rend la peau après on
peut moi je critique jamais tu le
physique béquilles que matériels sont
moins nombreux à monza alors on va
revoir cette scène regardez c'est elle
la plus grande star quand même de toute
l'histoire des télé crochets c'est un
truc nous et c'est vrai que quand on la
voit rien on se dit ça va être une dar k
et regardez c'est eddy place celli plate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais c'est elle avait gagné elle
a gagné d'ailleurs but
elle est au chômage quand elle est venue
faire décrocher
ça a complètement bouleversé sa vie face
à royal c'est une très jolie soit
l'histoire d'un méchant ça fait du monde
d'accord qu'on veut voir ici c'est des
histoires qu'on veut voir
alors en 2012 quand on mixe ex star de
téléréalité et télé crochet ça donne
encore une chance et où est-ce que vous
rappeler de ça encore une chance sur
nrj12 en ont fait un truc c'est un flop
total
la gagnante c'est lucie azard regardez
vous en rappelez peut-être c'était lille
28 ça sur nrj 12
je me rappelais pas du tout regardé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lucy lucy adar non non je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'était sur nrj12 du siasa
ont leur matelas est mignonne en tout
cas mais quelqu'un ces nouvelles
quelques a peut-être eu de ses nouvelles
voisins hélas non et enfin et ben non
mais moi je la trouve moi je trouvais
qu'elle a un talon je rigole pas j'aime
bien tu vois je trouve qu'il est bien
sûr en face en 2012 débute the voice est
adressé au vote
the rocks à débuter en 2012 les chéris
les audiences de samedi dernier pour de
vries 5 million deux cent mille
téléspectateurs tirés que ça voilà c'est
plus les audiences qui faisait avant
mais ça reste quand même très haut the
voice au départ c'était 11 millions de
téléspectateurs et cette année on l'a vu
ces dernières semaines les coaches se
tirent dans les pattes ils sont parfois
très ému et parfois il pète les plombs
sur leurs fauteuils
regardez ça c'est maintenant le télé
crochet voilà le plus gros télé crochet
ça reste encore de vries regarde
j'aurais pu dire d'abord un truc à toi
avant dire aux autres tous ceux qui vont
se mettre sur sa route
ils me trouveront en face
je l'avais dit la dernière fois à quel
point j'avais envie que j'étais heureux
que dans the voice y est voilà qu'on
écoute des artistes qui aiment cette
musique c'est pas facile hein donc je
souhaite remercier au nom tout le monde
ça fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]
rs et the voice maintenant et on a fait
l'histoire des télé crochets sté babara
kong